well here's a first I'm actually doing a
reira view of a Disney cember I did
hocus-pocus as allow you know what I saw
this film I really didn't like it in
fact I downright hated it to a point
where people were asking for years for
me to do a nostalgia critic of it I
finally did I sat down watched it again
and yeah I still didn't like it but I
will admit it wasn't quite as bad as I
remembered the movie was pretty obvious
in what I'm trying to say but if you
wanted a more down-to-earth talk about
it I guess that's what this video was
born so let's address the things I
didn't like about originally the big
focus was the virgin talk everybody gave
this kids such a hard time for him being
a virgin hell it's even the final line I
always remember that being a problem and
while it still is I'll admit it's not as
bad as I remember even when I did the
movie review I made a conscious effort
not to mention it as many times as the
movie does which i think is something
like four or five times that's still
weird but yeah it's wrong to say it's
the focus of the entire film I brought
up how the witches don't have anything
funny to say and that's still true but
watching it again I realize even though
they really don't have anything funny to
say they still kind of say it in a funny
way these three actresses are actually
really enjoyable you can't get the
feeling two weren't given anything to
work with but they just said screw it
we're gonna flour all into every single
moment we're on screen and it shows I
get the feeling they sort of huddled
together and talked about how they're
gonna move and what each one is gonna do
when the camera starts rolling does that
excuse the bad writing no but it does
kind of make it a little entertaining
these three are a lot of fun to watch
now does that excuse how incredibly
bland the main characters are no does
that excuse how this story makes
absolutely no sense whatsoever no does
that excuse a lot of really awkward just
downright stupid moments absolutely not
but over time I am realizing more and
more why this is getting a following and
that the correct terminology for it
really is guilty pleasure it's like my
love for Ernest saves Christmas it is a
stupid movie and nothing makes sense
about it but some things are just so
good I
can't help but watch it every year
hocus-pocus I can now see is kind of the
same way there is a lot of Halloween in
it there are a lot of nice visuals it's
over-the-top and cartoony but that just
kind of makes it stand out even more the
song sequence with her singing is a lot
of fun a lot of the effects actually
still kind of hold up and even all those
cliched 90s tropes I think people are
kind of laughing at how cliched they are
now and how you did see them just in
every kid's movie at the time it doesn't
mean it's by any means smart but I can
see how people can be really entertained
by it
it's not for me to say I actually enjoy
it but I do enjoy parts enough to at
least finally see why other people enjoy
it
and I think that's an important thing to
understand so I guess the conclusion of
this re-review is if you're really
forgiving and just want to see some
Halloween visuals you'll probably be
satisfied here or if you really like
those classic 90s tropes and you just
kind of want to have a laugh at them
you'll probably really like this too I
still really don't like those scenes
where they address the whole weird
virgin shaming but like I said it's not
as focused on as I remember it
so maybe the majority of kids watch it
will probably overlook that too and just
be distracted by how entertaining the
free witches are I just felt like this
movie deserved a second chance do I
still like it no but I can understand
why others like if this is something you
watch every Halloween I finally get it I
probably won't be joining the group but
I can at least say there are some really
fun and weird things about it that you
can get a few laughs out I'll enjoy my
incredibly silly stupid guilty pleasures
and you can enjoy yours
you